say welcome everybody and um
um
it's a pleasure to introduce uh shivaji
zombie who's the victim professor of
physics at oxford
uh so shivaji is a a is a condensed
matter physicists work extensively on
various aspects including logical phases
um he uh
he he
you know he's done various uh important
things like discovering skirmions and
the quantum hall effect and
the prediction of magnetic monopoles and
spin ice for which he won the eps euro
physics prize and so today he'll talk
about
[Music]
this open edit and the topic towards an
interactive quantum dynamics so shivaji
great
so thank you amesh for this uh
kind invitation um
so
um
what i'm
going to do is to sort of um
you know pitch a certain vision which is
uh certainly
not unique to me but it really involves
various people
on this
in the seminar as well as
others and more broadly i would say it's
shared by i guess a lot of people
working in the field
uh
and amazed himself uh i will give you
sort of my version of it um
which is the viewpoint of a sort of many
body physicist this is
primarily a seminar i guess in quantum
computing
and um
so i'm going to come at it from
a somewhat different angle which
hopefully will be useful when i'll build
the story around a recent
experiment i've done
at google
and uh tell you a little bit about it
but it will not primarily be
instrumental talk but bedroom russian
who did
you know
the
chief experimentalist uh will be on on
the panel and if
uh the questions are of interest is
without the details i'm sure he would be
delighted to
to address them
so i'm going to try and sort of uh
add omasha's explicit invitation try and
lay out a
somewhat broad vision
so i guess
at the risk of being ups that was not
right
um
at the risk of being
you know
overly
pedagogical let me just
remind all of us that you know sort of
quantum mechanics
is sort of fundamentally a theory of
the theory of unitary evolutions
plus sort of non-unitary measurements
when i say fundamentally i mean that in
practice
that's how it works
if you're a quantum cosmologist
you know
maybe it's fundamentally a theory of
unitary evolutions alone and then the
problem switches to
how you recover the world that you live
in
from a
unitary system of some description
perhaps close perhaps not
but in terms of sort of everyday physics
i think it's fair to say that it's
ethereal unitary evolutions and
non-unitary measurements
and i'm saying this instead of you know
sort of hamiltonians because
any experiment that you do any
phenomenon that you observe
you know has a start and finish and so
you really begin with getting from here
to there in time and then
from there you work backwards to
objects like hamiltonix
now nicely enough
a quantum computer
is
also a device
which is sort of made up of
you know the same ingredients
and it's not
because it must have the same
ingredients but the nice thing is that
the ingredients come in the form of a
toolkit
which you know we're all familiar with
in some sort of circuit model
i've got some set of
qubits which i can initialize
and then i've got various gates
you know that i can do of various range
and then
eventually or even before i can do
various measurements
and then maybe there's a final set of
measurements where i read things out
so
so what's nice is that the
these devices the ones which currently
exist and also the ones that will
eventually exist
um
very nicely directly
you know
put together these these ingredients
in the form of modules
and of course our unitary is going to be
constructed from some fundamental set of
gates which is chosen in order to do all
of that
now
the other thing which is
okay so if i just looked at this you
know i might say well
um
as a physicist um you know i had some
unitary evolution between an initial
state and final state and what's nice is
that i can simulate that evolution
on this device provided i can represent
the initial strength to some accuracy on
the initial set of qubits
maybe i can simulate the standard model
if i had a large enough device
and
and then using the gate set i can i can
construct any unitary so certainly i can
mimic
the
quantum evolution that i think is going
on somewhere else
on this device which is of course the
promise of quantum simulation
now what's interesting in some ways uh
is that
one can do something else you can
measure things in between
and
you can then
feed those measurements into a classical
computer
and feed them back
into
this content device in terms of what the
unitary evolution is going to be
when you look further down
now
this is not the way one normally thinks
in physics of you know experimental
systems
it's true that you have
an experimenter who does measurements
and you know but the idea that you
should be doing these sorts of
that you should be in this intimate
dialogue with the um you know time
evolution of a quantum system
where as you go along on the scales of
interest in the evolution microscopic
times
that you would be able to change what
happened subsequently
you know certainly strikes me as being
a new feature so that if we had a
quantum computer
sort of in dialogue with a classical
computer
viewed simply as a physical system if i
look at it from the outside
and say you know there are these two
machines plus equipment back and forth
and some quantum phonics is taking place
in the quantum system
this
certainly starts to look like sort of a
new physical system
well for practical purposes obviously
anything that exists as a physical
system is in principle is described by
the physics that we already understand
but
in practice in terms of you know
sort of studying it
and being able to do a theory of it and
the phenomena that one would expect to
see in it i think this is a very
different regime
and it's this
vision of having
a physical system which has this
classical computational aspect as well
as quantum evolution
which
you know
is
the interactive quantum dynamics of the
title
that here is something new
and by the time we're done exploring
the range of things such a device can do
that we would have
found physical phenomena which are
uh
very different from the ones that we are
currently
familiar with
so again i want to emphasize that one
you know i'm
a many body physicists so this is you
know from my point of view this is a
talk on
many body physics
right
so
um so what that what that means is the
following
which is i'm going to imagine
at the end of the day that i've got n
qubits
uh that this number will eventually be
taken to be large
that whatever i'm doing is going to be
sort of statistically
homogeneous
um
action
on the qubits
okay so what i mean by that is if you
think of them as sort of arranged of
course being physicists
you know we typically will think of them
being arranged one dimensionally or two
dimensionally or three dimensionally
although sometimes also
in fancier ways so that whatever is the
circuit and set of measurements that
acts on them will have the property that
you know different parts of the system
will roughly look the same statistically
so typically a many-body physicist isn't
interested in
the action of a structure
you know which is spatially very very
carefully organized now there are
exceptions to this you sometimes you're
interested in a fractal arrangement
because that's theoretically interesting
but typically that's what many body
physicists like to do the reason i bring
that up is to say that a you know if i'm
looking at qubits and the action of a
circuit and measurements of course any
quantum algorithm
uh does exactly that
but
it's more than likely that from the
point of view of any body physicist
most quantum algorithms are going to be
very special evolutions maybe with you
know a particular structure
on the space of cubits which is not
necessarily something that we would be
interested in we might be interested in
more genetic behavior
so that's just something to keep in mind
that you know
many body physicists looks at the object
sitting in the lab and says oh neat this
is a new physical system let me run it
in the way that i
you know normally like to do things
and see what i find
okay the other aspect is that a many
body physicists would normally or
quantum statistical mechanic would think
of
sort of you know you you have some
adolescent which is made up of these
unitarian unitary components and you're
going to look at times
which are somehow
long compared to individual gates for
example
so this comes from our
interest in long wavelengths and and
long times
and that's
very much part of the
what makes you know many body physics is
interested in the behavior of many
bodies we're interested in what happens
which is sharpening new
uh in the limit of an infinite number of
degrees of freedom
okay so
so that i guess so the main thing i want
to say at the start is that
you know someone like myself
is interested in these devices coming
into being the risk devices which exist
now and the ones which come into the
future from this viewpoint which
probably will not overlap with
those particular circuits and
arrangements which are you know really
interesting for solving particular
computation problem which will be
imposed by something else
but hopefully they will do things which
are
interesting otherwise and sometimes
perhaps there will be an intersection
where
something that looks like a new physical
phenomenon will also turn out to be
interesting computation
um
very recently the google quantum
supremacy experiment was a case where
many body physicists looked to that and
said oh meat that's the minimum model
for quantum you know ergodicity and
that was also reinterpreted
interesting in terms that seemed
interesting to
computer scientists
all right good
so
the next question is um
you know
what
might happen in these devices which is
sort of new from the you know many body
viewpoints so
i mean after all
if the quantum computer is simulating
you know anything
whatsoever it certainly is simulating
things that we already
studied
so
let me say something
very
cartoonish for a moment
which is to say
you could say that a huge amount of many
body physics consists of starting with
some you know subtle qubits
acting on it with some
circuit which
effectively implements right
just unitary evolution with some
specified hamiltonian typically with
some nice properties
in space where the qubits are arranged
in space
and then you get to some final state
in all of this
is to say that you get a final state
which is obtained from some initial
state
by
the action of a unitary which is
generated by a hamilton
now
um
the sort of thing
that
a huge amount of work in the field you
know
goes into cases where
the final state
is
an equilibrium state
right which is to say
if i take some
reasonably defined subset of the system
the reduced density matrix on it ends up
looking like
something like e to the minus beta h
restricted to that region
so this is
you know these are ergodic hamiltonians
and then if you know that this is true
at long times
that the system approaches equilibrium
then there's this enormous machinery of
quantum statistical mechanics in one
field theory which is brought to bear in
thinking about the properties so what
you do is you compute with with this
beast and that i'm done looks like a
path interval and you can do all sorts
of marvelous and wonderful things with
it
now in terms of probing it
you generally probe you know but in
linear response theory
which you should think of as a you know
weak
interaction or a weak
right with the system
i don't use a term weak measurement
which has a which has a precise meaning
but
so that's
in cartoon that's the most common
thing that we are going to do
that we have done traditionally
in looking at quantum systems
now from the viewpoint of what a quantum
computer can do
this is sort of limited there all sorts
of stuff i could have done in the middle
which i didn't do
uh i could have measured things i could
have felt the information back in the
system
and then the particular unitary itself
is very special it's generated by a
permission operator the hamiltonian
so when you combine the two
it seems fairly clear that the set of
things that we've looked at
is um
is potentially a small fraction of the
set of things that could exist the full
set of evolutions in this
device with the combination of you know
unitaries and machines
of course it's been
good to do what we've done partly
because systems equilibrate
and you look around and you know that
is a wonderful set of things to study
and second of course as i mentioned that
the theoretical tools available to deal
with equilibrium calculations
are superb
and
so of course one wishes to use them
okay
now i'm absolutely exaggerating which is
to say of course non-equilibrium
phenomena have been a long of interest
to
physicists
the boltzmann equation was written down
to try and understand how
an equilibrium state would indeed be
reached there's also
the extensions of the boltzmann equation
to
quantum systems
which you can you know which are more
complicated even the boltzmann equation
itself
you know has
uh issues regarding its fundamental
validity
but nevertheless those are you know in
practice
interesting and useful and productive
ways of thinking about how systems
approach equilibrium there's the topic
of hydrodynamics so what you know which
is sort of near equilibrium physics and
much more importantly in uh
in in recent i was in at least the last
decade but more
the advent of um called
atoms which are really
a close
you know system to
these systems which make up the devices
that we're now starting to look at has
certainly inspired a an entire field of
non-equilibrium quantum dynamics in
which people have looked at all sorts of
things often with you know some
combination of tools such as analytic
models like random circuits as well as a
huge amount of computational work which
has become possible due to advances in
classical computation but nevertheless
if you walked into an experimental lab
the typical experiment would indeed
still involve
you know lowering the temperature
waiting for the system to settle
measuring something
okay
now i mentioned cold atom just to say
that um
you know there's a tendency to say well
x came by and nothing like this has been
ever seen before but in fact gold atoms
are a wonderful system
um
and
already allow all sorts of you know
heroics in terms of what you can do and
so on
they themselves are successors to a
whole tradition of generating artificial
and physical systems going back to
two-dimensional electron gases forwards
to twisted value of graphene
so
maybe a more accurate view of what's
going on is that there is a something
which is q-i-d-ness in terms of what you
can do
and this is time
and you know there's some curve like
that
and i would say we are here in 2021
which is absolutely things have been
happening
but i think there's reason to think that
the new generation devices will really
accelerate the process so by the time we
look back from here to where we were
back then i think we will say a few have
been founded but of course you know
you're absolutely entitled to complain
that
there's a question on the q a which
might help sharpen this a little bit so
so i think the question is just asking
for clarification does the interactive
aspect here refer to the use of
measurement based feedback to steer the
dynamics in real time
and so is that
is that the y-axis
uh okay so that's uh that's certainly
one part of it and that's uh the part
that i understand best
but the the term itself is borrowed from
you know uh our friends and computer
science such as amish and i think um
you know they've shown that
that you know using sort of cs ideas
that you can
actually constrain the behavior uh so
that that's a
slightly different idea although i guess
at the end of the day you know there's
still this notion that you ask certain
questions and then you do certain things
so
so i would say that it's some mix of
things i understand and things i don't
understand which is you know
sort of uh
the cs aspects of you know thinking of
interactivity in a more precise sense
so while we added there was another
question which just asked what does qid
stand for so
quantum interactive dynamics
so that's
borrowing shamelessly from qed and qcd
that's it proceed
yes yes
okay actually
please interrupt
it's slightly below my screen so i can't
necessarily see that that well when the
questions pop up
all right good
um
excellent
okay so the next thing i want to do is
to say that this new toolkit like this
capacity to be in
a much more intimate contact with the
system
uh it's already allowing new phenomena
to be demonstrated in the lab which
would be sort of impossible in more
traditional you know many body systems
and as an example i'll discuss the
phenomenon of eigenstate order
in the mbl time crystal which was seen
in this google quantum processor so i'll
give you a high level view of what you
know that was about
and
i i won't get that much into the time
crystal aspect that's actually not so
interesting to the context of our
discussion today
but what is actually interesting is is
the idea of eigenstate order and and why
you need such a device to be able to you
know to see this phenomenon and and what
tricks which are
in the in the air
uh were very useful in in our in our
seeing it
so
i now want to discuss this
phenomenon of eigenstate order
in
an mdl
crystal
um
okay
and so
observation
a quantum processor
all right
so
um
let me get to that so what is the uh you
know
okay
so
so first of all
this is a phenomenon in a flowcase
system
right
so
in canaanites matter jargon
it means
that
there is
a
the system has a time dependent
hamiltonian which is periodic
and therefore
if you want to know
what is the
unitary if you go n periods
then that's equal to some single period
unitary
raised to the power
so it's not the most general unitary you
can have
on the other hand uh
it's neither is it
right it is not e to the minus i h t
so it's not a time independent
hamiltonian
it is a driven system
so as such it's already out of
equilibrium
the only kind of equilibrium it could
have from the principles of statistical
mechanics would be that the system heats
up to infinite temperature
and then everything is totally
featureless
just because once you no longer have a
conserved energy
then
statistical mechanics tells you that you
can't have something like e to the minus
beta h because that came from saying
that you had an energy that was
conserved
all right
so
um good
now
the particular
unitary which gives us this phase
uh is something which acts on a set of
qubits arising spins
and
what that looks like
is
that
you act
in
um
so okay let me let me just write down
the ingredients which is to say
you act for some part of the period
with something that looks like
i
z i plus 1.
so in
physics jargon it's an ising
interaction
and then in the second part you act with
something that looks like
a transverse field
it's on a single site
okay so notice that i put down so this
system physics-wise is organized
one-dimensionally so it really does look
like the the picture of qubits arranged
in a row i have nearest neighbor
interactions and things that will come
on on-site
so
so so this happens over a certain period
and then this happens over
you know a certain period which are
built into the values of j
and gap
now
you need some amount of randomness in
these couplings so jra is going to be
some average value plus some
fluctuations
and gamma i is going to give you some
average value plus some fluctuations
now
what you get when you analyze this
problem
is a
phase diagram
as a function of these
average values
and of course
i'm being
you know somewhat sloppy in the sense
that you do have to fret about the
fluctuations
which has this sort of
structure
where
if you don't have a transverse field and
all you have is a an exchange
interaction
then
it's a problem if i just go back here
if all i'm doing is acting with this
piece well of course that is the case of
the time independent hamiltonian which
is sitting up there multiplied by some
time
if i'm only acting with the second piece
then again it's a tremendous dependent
hamiltonian it's when i switch between
these two that my hamiltonian now has
time dependence this case a very simple
one it's a sort of binary dependence
it's you know one or the other but
that's enough to take us out of the
class of hamiltonian time independent
hamiltonian systems into floquet systems
so this axis
has
just an icing exchange and therefore you
expect it to
have long range order in in spins
i'll call this phase a spin glass for a
reason i'll explain shortly
and then this if i only have uh you know
this axis then i have
what we call the izing paramagnet
so these are
traditional phases studied and time
independent systems except that when you
add a little bit of the other thing they
sort of continue even though now the
hamiltonian is somewhat time dependent
and then
here is this phase which has become
famous as the distributed time crystal
although initially we had called it the
pi spin glass and you'll see in a minute
why because it has a
close intimate connection to this spin
glass and finally this is something
which we call the zero pi
paramagnet which i won't
discuss today
now
the randomness i mentioned is
extraordinarily important to be able to
actually draw the space diagram
if all i had were uniform couplings then
this axis would be fine and that axis
would be fine
uh and
you know i mean
the boundaries would be fine but once
you've moved a little bit away from the
boundary in the absence of randomness
actually you would heat up to infinite
temperature and there would be nothing
interesting to observe
so so physics wise it's very important
that there be this randomness there has
to be sufficient randomness to cause
this phenomenon of many body
localization which for practical
purposes means you don't equilibrate and
more intuitively it means that you sort
of get stuck
in
in hebrew space you don't you don't move
around as much
okay
so
um
good
now what is
how do i tell that i've got you know
sort of this face
so
so
there's an answer that i can give uh you
know as a as a theorist
and then there's the question of uh you
know
what answer is actually useful if i'm
going to go to an experiment
okay
so
the answer as a theorist
is
that
this face for example
like any unitary has eigenvalues that
live on a circle and so if i look in
this dtc phase
what i find is
that
the eigenvalues of the unitary
in the limit of in our system
come in pairs which live
diametrically opposite right so they
form a pi pair so once it's here and the
other side's here there's one sits here
and once it's there so
there's an important question
it says is the only difference between
this floquet evolution and authorized
evolution of the transistorizing model
that you aren't constrained to having to
evolve under a small time step which is
of course very important
uh is the only difference
that you aren't constrained to about
having to evolve under a small time step
uh
i
guess that's
i guess that's right
yeah i mean the point is that if you
these phases if you put the limits on
your face boundary at pi over two right
the the normal phases exist when you're
j
right and your h are are comparable to
the frequency right that was the
challenge so then uh
in the limit yeah right right you know
so the question
i guess i hadn't thought about it that
way that if the trotter error you know
the trotter interval is
is not infinitesimal which it is in the
theorist sense when you do it i guess
eventually you're
you're doing floquet
which i hadn't thought about but i guess
that's true
yeah i mean this strict characterization
is the limit where that time integral
goes to zero and and this is absolutely
when things are finite
sorry
can i can i ask these these two axes
they are the frequency with which you
with which you apply the two
uh different hamiltonians uh
okay so
so i so you can think of the first one
as imagine that you
during this interval capital t
maybe you go from zero to you know you
you have some tau one and
let's call it t1 and t2 right such that
t1 plus t2
is equal to capital t
so so this number maybe you know if i
think of them as exchange constants i
can then replace it by
you know the fact that it's this is the
hamiltonian and i'm multiplying it by t1
this is the hamiltonian and i'm
multiplying by t2
so it's really a composite of these two
that
you
decides
what is it that you're doing
and you're alternating back and forth
for t
that's right first one then the other
one
okay good
um
right
okay
so
to understand that this is special let's
walk across to this side and look on
this axis so this axis all we had
was this you know sum over i j i
z i z i plus 1
times let me now write it as they just
said times t 1.
so this is a unitary but if you're
interested in understanding its spectrum
you really just need to think about the
spectrum of the hamiltonian
and that we know has the feature that
because this one has an ising symmetry
right i could send
the eigenvalue of zi to minus zi
alongsides and i would get exactly the
same energy
so if i think of the the spindas which
i'm calling the spin glass that has a
whole bunch of states where there are
two states right right on top of each
other so the first one is there and the
second one is there the first one is
there and the second one is there
whereas in the pi spin class the first
one is here and the second one is there
the first one is here and the second one
is there
so
in both cases there is a doublet that
emerges in the spectrum
but in the
floquet phase the doublet is actually
split by pi
i can i mean it wouldn't take very long
for you to see in the simplest case that
that's true
all you need to do is to think about
this axis and what you will discover
there is that the unitary ends up
looking like the following which is it's
got this j i z i z i plus one
but the in the limit that the
disorder in gamma is extremely narrow
this value
pi over 2
is chosen so that the net result of the
transpose field is to flip the spins
exactly into z basis so this is the
eisen flip operator and so then it's
easy to convince yourself that if you
had an eigenstate of this
then what it does is it flips it to the
izing pair and so the eigenvalues end up
being in your cats which is any
particular spin configuration plus or
minus it's eisen reverse counterpart and
these are the states that end up having
eigenvalues so in one case there's a
schrodinger cat you know so you get plus
minus one
times some eigenvalue
which i'm now writing classically
these are operators
and
this plus minus one is exactly this pie
shift across the
uh
across the circle
so
um
actually maybe i should say two things
at the same time so with this the eigen
states are
uh you know z1 through zn
plus or minus z1 bar through zn bar
where think of the bar as as being
something which is reflected
and this unitary acting and then
gives me plus or minus
z plus minus c bar
so the reason we call this phase the
spin glass
is because every eigen state
of the spectrum now on on the left
boundary the eigenstate is basically
just
either z's or z bars
right
uh only one or the other but each one of
them has long range order in the z basis
which is if you calculate z i z j the
correlation function you know that does
not go to zero as i minus j
goes to infinity which is the
physicist's definition of long range
order
so that's true along this axis
and it's also true along this axis
because the shorter cats have the same
feature but nevertheless the two phases
are not the same and that's because the
eigenvalues of the unitary have a
different
structure
and a different double instruction
okay
so
so that's the
the theorist view of the of the time
crystal that it's a
you know it's a flowcase phase where the
you know unitaries have this feature in
the spectrum and the eigenstates of the
unitaries have long intruder in the
canonical sense of um
you know quantum statistical mechanics
so
the the upshot of that is that if you
imagine that you have a
sorry sorry
[Music]
um
so sorry uh
very quickly um so can can you can you
see in in a sentence the the distinction
between the spin glass and the and the
time crystal was exactly what so you you
have this
sure
so let me write it in the next one
so in the spin glass
so formally i can define a single period
unitary although there's really a
hamiltonian and the eigen states are z1
through zn
right
and this is degenerate
with
z1 bar
through z and bar where each bar
indicates a noisy reversal
and
they have the same eigenvalue
okay so in other words
both of them uh u on this
or that
gives me some e to the i lambda at times
you know the state itself
okay
um whereas
in the in the time crystal
u on
z1 i said let me just call it z plus or
minus c bar so the eigenstates and i'll
be showing your cats what it's going to
do too if i want to be
r
you know it gives me e to the i lambda
plus or minus 1
times z plus or minus c bar
so that's that that's the difference
identical eigenvalues and then the fact
that the eigenstates
are necessarily
and have this microscopic superposition
and then as i move back in the phase
diagram
into the interior of the phase diagram
right the picture gets more complicated
but there's
a set of variables
in terms of which
this continues to be true
so far so good yeah
okay
all right
now
the
in an experiment you're not going to go
measure uh you know the eigen vectors of
the of the unitary and more than you
measure eigens vectors and hamiltonians
and many body systems
so in order to
measure things in an experiment
you have to realize that what happens
as you evolve a given initial state
is that
something
very
simple happens so again in the picture
that i'm describing for these idealized
minutes
what happens is
if you
think of this unitary
right
and you think of it as acting on some
particular state in the z basis
this one just picks up the phase and
this one flips it
so in the idealized limit you see that
what's going to happen is you've got
some state you know up down up up down
and at the next time step this is going
to become down this is going to become
right they'll just flip and at the next
time step you'll go back to what you
used to be
so this is step zero period one period
two and so on and so forth
so in this idealized case you see
and this that
the
starting initial state actually repeats
uh after period two
and so the reason this thing came to be
called the time crystal is that the
unitary itself repeats after period one
but the state repeats after two periods
which is you know the sort of
standard way in which you get a broken
symmetry you have a symmetry of the
dynamics but the but the state does not
respect
okay now again as you move away from
these idealized you know
limits in which you can write these very
simple pictures it's not obvious that
all this works
but it does
and so what will happen is that if you
feed it something like this it will get
modified you're not going to get you
know perfect but nevertheless at long
times there is a remnant magnetization
which at sufficiently long times will
repeat this pattern
uh with with ethereum two so you've got
to wait a while you've got to evolve it
but eventually
you know that will do it
so
that tells you
uh
you know how to go about
looking experimentally for this
phenomenon
which is to say
you give this you know you so you you
give your quantum processor
a
multiple initial strings produced in the
uh you know computational or z basis
you act on it with the floquet unitary
implemented on the quantum processor
some number of times
then you do a measurement and then you
want to check that for
you know every single configuration that
you could feel it it's going to show
this phenomenon
at long times
okay
so
now at this point
i've actually slipped in the idea
of eigenstate order
right so
traditionally in the sort of
in many body physics
um
you look
if you're looking for interesting
quantum phenomena you look near the
ground state
and um
and you know a quantum phase transition
for instance involves something that you
know is just a ground state
so it's really a relatively small part
of the spectrum that you focus on then
you have a finite temperature phase
transitions where generally in the
traditional understanding the phenomenon
ultimately ends up being
you know fairly classical in terms of
some variables
and then
even in that case
if you go to high enough temperatures
the phenomenon disappears like your
typical ordering transition in a canasta
system superconductivity magnetism is a
phenomenon up to some finite temperature
but of course if you're thinking from
the viewpoint of the hilbert space most
of the states in the hilbert space
are actually
you know near infinite temperature so
your typical ordering phenomenon
in an equilibrium system
takes place for a vanishing fraction
of the states you know it's a some
suitable set of states in hilbert space
here the the statement has been made is
that every single eigenstate of the
unitary
exhibits
this ordering
which is much stronger than anything you
would have tried to discuss previously
and the central part of this is many
body localization which means that you
don't equilibrate it also means that
you're able to stabilize ordering in
states that you would normally think of
as having high energy
so there's also a hamiltonian version of
what i'm describing in which case you
can literally talk about the energy
so again this phenomenon of eigenstate
order is really new it's a real
departure in quantum statistical
mechanics
because it's something which
is not captured by an equilibrium
example indeed if you use the
corresponding naive equilibrium ensemble
you wouldn't see this phenomenon at all
but you learn it if you examine the
eigenspace individually and then you can
detect it in this dynamical fashion by
starting with the whole ensemble of
states evolving them and seeing what
happens at late times
so in the spirit of our discussion today
i want to emphasize that you know
preparing the whole slew of such states
in your traditional solid state system
is simply not possible when you
typically equilibrate some temperature
and you vary that to try and get states
uh you know near low temperatures and up
to certain temperature you really
couldn't look at these states which
would be infinite temperature by some
some metric and you wouldn't be able to
get to them so you really need these new
devices
where you can really target the initial
you know a strain of this kind that you
are trying to
so far so good
okay
so
um
so what was needed to be done i'm a bit
concerned that i can't see a
clock it's 11.50
okay
so i should actually
stop in 10 minutes right
so okay
so what was done in the in the
experiment with the google team was to
use their
you know device
and
maybe i just point to some pictures
in
let's say for
okay so as you can see
there's the statement of what happens
when you have uh
you know sort of a perfect alignment
and when you don't which is on the other
side
so
okay so
basically
using their native you know gate set
we were able to
sit on this phase diagram that i i
discussed something actually i neglected
to say which is which is also important
it's a somewhat different idea
is that i talked about
the initial model in terms of a model
which has ising symmetry it had very
special couplings as easy and next
actually one of the remarkable aspects
of this phase is that it's absolutely
stable meaning that once you've found it
you can add any weak time-dependent
perturbation of the hamiltonian it
doesn't have to have any particular
symmetry and yet the phenomenon survives
so that's very useful also from an
experimental viewpoint
but it's also important to check you
know that's true so in fact
in the you know in the experiments um
that happens
naturally and that made it also a
very useful phenomenon to look for uh
because you were not trying to fine tune
symmetry in order to find
so you've got initial random bit strings
which you feed into a flowcase system
you know flowcase circuit
and then as you vary parameters you know
you're looking for
differences like what you see here
that
in you know
uh either you're going to see oscillator
let's look look down here
you know either in a thermal phase
you're going to lose the initial
magnetization that you had imprinted or
in an indian discrete time crystal
you're going to see it go on
you know for a very long time
now
one thing
to mention is of course when you do the
experiment straightforwardly
right what you see is stuff that decays
right
now it could be decaying for two reasons
it could be decaying because it's an
experimental limitation which of course
exists these are imperfect devices it's
not perfect unitary evolution so you're
going to get dephasing from the
environment
or it could be decaying because the
qubit in question sees the rest of the
system as a dephasing environment which
is sort of intrinsic defacing but that's
physical that's because you know in the
thermalizing system that's what's going
to happen
so one of the things you want to try and
tell
is whether the decay that you're seeing
is coming from extrinsic sources or
intrinsic sources
and one of the powerful features of this
device is that there's a natural way to
do that and which is basically
you know shown sort of sketched here
that you can
run this unitary forwards
and then backwards
right
and
if it's intrinsic dephasing
a result of unitary evolution then of
course you'll undo it
but if it's extrinsic defazing you won't
you know you'll double it so you're able
to use that
to extract the the part of the decay
that you think is coming from extrinsic
sources imperfections and then you can
take ratios of the signal that you see
to what you estimate as the
extrinsic dephasing and that then gives
you
signals that are much more sharply
distinct between the thermal phase and
the discrete time crystal so again
it's the fact that you can do these
tricks on these devices right is is very
very important
um
to to being able to see this physics
now i mentioned that you want to check
what happens for
all initial strings now of course as the
system gets bigger
uh you know you're not going to be able
to
initialize so i think we did it for 500
but you know for 20 we didn't do it for
20.
but then there's another trick you can
use which is again very specific to
these devices
namely that you can
use the
you know random circuits that were used
in the
quantum supremacy experiment to start
with some string
and then act with this random circuit
and get a state here
which is actually
um
you know
sort of
close to a higher random step for
practical purposes and once you have a
higher random state
uh what the what you call quantum
typicality tells you that that state
while it's a single state but it's it
has the properties of an infinite
temperature ensemble
so you can prepare a single state by
using first unitary's mimicking random
circuit then feed that into the floquet
evolution and in that fashion you can
average over
all the initial strings
at one go
you don't sit there and make make each
one
so that's another very powerful trick
which is possible by using what we know
about these devices in the manner in
which we can use them which again means
that you have a way of averaging over
the entire spectrum
which is scalable you can just make
bigger devices and use the same trick
and be able to do it so you're not
stymied by the fact that you would have
to prepare infinitely many
starting states
um
so
so both of these are important and as a
result of that we were able to convince
ourselves
that we had
a capacity to see the phenomenon and not
see the phenomenon
to be able to tell the difference
between intrinsic dephasing and
extrinsic dephasing
and to convince ourselves
that it was an eigen state order
phenomenon which is to say it was
present throughout the spectrum there
have been previous experiments on you
know
claiming to see time crystals but they
have seen what in the jargon would be
called a free thermal time crystal which
for our purposes means that only a
vanishing fraction of the initial
strings actually had the capacity to
produce oscillations
at long times and that the typical one
actually did not
so this was you know very important for
us to be able to to do this
um okay
so
i guess i've got three minutes left
so maybe um
i should um
say a few things uh
back here
so you know so so what happens next
um
so what next
okay so the first thing i should mention
um is that there's actually a beautiful
body of work in which i have not been
involved myself except very little at
the start
which is on
measurement induced phase transitions
so
the work that i described to you
we didn't use really use the full tool
kit of you know being able to
interleave unitary evolution and
measurement so we certainly used some of
the bag of tricks which is available on
these content devices capacity to
initialize
you know create superpositions
um of you know states which are roughly
high random
but this theoretical work and
measurement and due space transitions
actually interleaves unitary evolution
and measurements in a fundamental way
and basically what happens in in this
work is you've got a set you act with
you know various unitary gates
and then you also interleave them with
measurements
and the question was
you know if you
measure at a certain rate
you know do you
you know do you destroy
quantumness and drive the system
classical for example if you ask about
the entanglement if you didn't have the
measurement the entanglement would be
going
towards the evolving level but if you
have measurements
would it
would any measurements you know
basically disentangle the system so the
the answer turned out to be no that
there are actually interesting phase
transitions that separate the regimes
where you get a volume entanglement and
you don't
there there's a lot of beautiful detail
that has come out the connections to
even long-standing problems in
statistical mechanics and from field
theory connections to cfd
and
presumably it's only a matter of time
that
something like this will be demonstrated
in one of these devices and that will
take you take us
i think deeper into this qid territory
because it's a phenomenon that you know
genuinely
could not have existed in the absence of
being able to measure and
do unitary evolution the next step would
be then some feedback in which you do
measurements and you and you do
something else on top of it i suppose
just measuring it and continuing on
with the plan that you had to begin with
so
i think that's roughly what i wanted to
say and i think i've come to stop at an
hour
so
i'll stop
thank you
that's exactly on exactly at noon so um
thanks a lot shivaji those that was
excellent so um are there any
are there any further questions
before we move on to the panel
um
so at this point if if there's a
question you can just speak up
um
otherwise um
maybe
if we can if we can start pinning the
the videos of the
of the panelists um
so shivaji if you if you would stop the
sharing then maybe